this video was sponsored by curiosity
stream and nebula I would actually say
we kind of discovered String Theory too
early we landed upon upon this thing
that looks incredibly promising and it
contains all the bits of physics that we
see in our universe in a very
constrained way but the energies that
says we should see these things that are
so above anything we can detect it's
kind of sad in a way yeah this sounds
like you're blaming the experiment
please no no I'm not blaming these
parameters I mean this is just the
practicalities of the universe lots of
people follow this YouTube channel
because of the Vlogs I made during my
PhD in atmospheric physics at the
University of Exeter unfortunately
however I had to graduate at some point
and that necessarily meant the end of my
videos showing what doing a PhD was like
however there are lots of people out
there doing interesting PhD projects and
so in this video series I'm spending a
few days with a new researcher each
episode showing you what that life is
like learning a bit about them and
learning about the topic of their thesis
this time I'm spending a few days with
Thomas who's studying for a PhD in
string theory at the University of
Oxford but before we talk about that let
me ask a question that you may well have
what exactly is string theory if you can
answer that you'd probably win a
fundamental physics prize the best
definition I would say for what string
theory is is it's a special limits of M
Theory which that makes you ask what is
M Theory there are definitely statements
you can make that you'd expect to be in
a universe where string theory is true
if we live in the universe with string
theory what can we definitely rule out
if that makes sense which is then which
that means if you were to detect any of
these things you know String Theory
would have to be wrong I mean these days
if someone calls themselves a string
theorist that doesn't even necessarily
mean they're working in the theory of
kind of Quanto strings in terms it means
generically almost lots of different
things going on informal formal
theoretical physics and mathematical
physics there are people who are working
other other theories of quantum gravity
string theory is just the best
understood and the best developed of
these theories now I have a background
in physics and even I think this is
tough to conceptualize so don't worry if
you're struggling because this video
isn't just about the physics it's about
life as a research student at Oxford and
about life after being a research
student at Oxford this main thing I've
been working on is using techniques or
from geometry and machine learning
coupled together to try and construct
semi-realistic models of particle
physics from string thing this maybe
gives you some hint of what could come
next if string theories to be true
rather than looking at what we have
right now and then trying to guess at
things that could fit in the holes why
do this why do this it's interesting and
it feels I think it's me personally it
feels somewhat less undirected maybe
understanding the world is something
that's
we should just aim for as a species I
don't know maybe that's the best the
best answer I can give this is a
Bittersweet video for me coming back to
Oxford and to the physics department
specifically I did my undergraduate
degree in physics here and if you
followed my channel for a while you know
that the experience wasn't an entirely
happy one for me in fact some of you may
recognize Thomas from the video I made
about revisiting my experience studying
Quantum field theory in my Master's year
he acted as a kind of consultant so this
building was built after I was at the
zoo's Department he actually joins the
building I was taught in but it's it's
pretty spectacular I think there's a
famous quote from Einstein that's
basically like all he needed was paper
pencil and a waste paper bin in order to
do his research and you know this
facility is basically just a big Atrium
in the middle like a big Courtyard and
then offices surrounding it and they all
just have spaces to write in that's it
that's all you need to do theoretical
physics okay so currently this is pretty
typical so open on the computer is just
normally emails and slack for random
people contacting me on the right hand
side though they normally have
Mathematica open so then this is just a
bunch of calculations that well I'm
going back and forth between pen and
paper calculations random collections of
pages and notes and
all sorts of different things depending
on whatever I'm working on at the time
and then of course behind you this isn't
my writing on it right now but then
there's always someone who's been
working on on the Blackboard you may
think it s area type the theoretical a
physicist generally in theoretical
physicists in particular have these they
are everywhere in this department like
every surface is a Blackboard pretty
much
I've wanted a PhD for a long long time I
was definitely in secondary school when
I was first thinking about it and I
think it's I was interested in doing
some kind of scientific research and so
then PhD isn't the natural way to go and
then especially if as I became more
interested in theoretical physics then
that's how you get into theoretical
physics kind of knew what uh doing a PhD
was going to be I mean I spoke to lots
of people doing phds once in my
undergrad watched your videos so I saw a
lot of it from there as well and yeah
it's kind of what I expected and I'm
enjoying it so you're a rare breed so
taking a string theory in particular one
type of string theory called E8 across
the a titratic string three and this
lives in 10 Dimensions so you need some
way to try and connect it to the three
plus one Dimensions that we have for
that plus one is is time so you need to
wrap up your extra dimensions in some
way but if we have some manifold I could
write this as being say R so it's just
real numbers times something else one
example of this could be just R3 which
would be three-dimensional space so this
is now a four dimensional this is now a
four-dimensional manifold however
I could imagine we lived in a universe
which was instead R2 cross again S1 well
S1 is a circle still four-dimensional
still four-dimensional but a circle say
this circle was incredibly small in
which case if you were living on this
space you may not even know this thing
even exists you'd think that you were in
you think you'd think you're actually in
some effective space
[Applause]
which would be this time across uh
two-dimensional space so you're actually
in a four-dimensional space but your
effective space that you experience yes
you think is two-dimensional yeah right
well two plus one so all I'm doing for
the string through case is we're saying
we actually have some 10 dimensional
space okay and I want to write this as
using similar annotations above r13
which just means one time Dimension
three spatial dimensions okay cross some
extra six dimensions
which is then normally for the kind of
compactifications I'm looking at taking
to be something called a clavio manifold
that's sort of your way of squirreling
all the extra Dimensions away into a
structure that you're not aware of yeah
normally yeah and this has only becomes
accessible at really high energies yeah
so as you go to higher and higher
energies you'd start to notice these
extra wankings exist in your research
then it's working out
what form this takes yeah what could you
choose for this and how do you search
for this now the space of possible
constructions there is vast absolutely
incredibly incredibly huge and the vast
majority of these will look nothing like
particle physics there's a challenge of
then trying to make constructions that
what you end up with then does start to
like particle physics and so what I've
been doing is using in particular
machine learning techniques to give a
family of these constructions to a
computer and allow it to modify it in a
way until what it's left with is a
particular compactification that the 4D
physics looks like the standard model
the first way we attempt to do this is I
give it literally one particular
compactification which will look nothing
at the center model and then I train it
to get points essentially by doing small
adjustments to this compactification
getting closer and closer towards a
standard model if it's moving away from
stuff like the standard model we start
giving it negative points and so over
time it trains how it gets higher and
higher points I think it's closer and
closer to the standard model so really
try and treat what we're doing as a game
where the objective of the game is find
the standard model in the space and then
it can then appear at random places in
this and it has to run to a nearby
standard model there is no in and out
data there's just an environment
widget's exploring and the environment
is so huge you could never scan it
directly with a computer so instead of
doing this kind of targeted searching by
knowing what you want to end up with as
a rule of thumb physics looks more
intimidating on the page or on the
Blackboard up to a point
and then when you see something like
this
that's actually pretty simple to write
down
run the more simple something looks on
the page if you're in a high level
Institute like this the more complicated
it is like this is far far beyond my
ability to understand
[Music]
this was home for me for four years I'm
actually walking towards where I lived
in my first year and uh it's very A
lot's changed like they built a lot of
new buildings and things look different
but it feels
very very familiar walking around when I
was last here physics kind of undid me
but now two things are different firstly
I'm with my wife and secondly so here on
Broad Street in Oxford which is opposite
the history of Science Museum and the
chardonian theater which is where you
graduate there's a Bookshop called
Blackwells and when I was a student I
used to come in here all the time
because they had an amazing amazing room
full of books about science now I've
come back out of the rain to look for a
specific book
[Music]
foreign
[Laughter]
[Music]
oh wait I'm right next to Jeremy Hunt
A lot's changed since I was here
if you told me when I was in the first
year and looking around this shop but
I'd have a book in here one day
never would have believed you
[Music]
so where are we going now uh so we're
just going to go to a seminar given by a
couple of students who just finished
their first year I did it um last year
yeah where the first year your class is
like a probationary research student and
then you can get promoted to be a full
deferral or PhD student and it's worth
stating I'm not allowed to film this so
this is this is yet more classic
Oxbridge behind closed doors but um
we'll talk to you afterwards so we're
out the other side of that seminar and
uh Thomas over here and we're also
joined by Ryan Ryan who was one of the
speakers at the seminar I knew very
graciously agreed to sort of give a
brief overview of what you were talking
about so I work in quantum gravity what
that is is trying to understand how to
combine general relativity that we know
works very well and um and quantum
mechanics and so one way to approach
this and what quantum gravity is is if
you had a space with some matter in it
it Curves in one particular way in order
to add quantumness in fuzziness you know
in a way you imagine you take a spare
for example it's not just a sphere but
it's more like a fuzzy sphere so you're
considering all possible ways it could
be bent if you've ever played a video
game and you've looked at sort of things
in the video game like say you have a
ball you've noticed it's not
particularly round it might be it's like
polygonized one way of doing that is to
triangulate it so you've got triangles
everywhere and that can give you sort of
an approximation to a sphere and so what
I'm doing is similar to that you
approximate the space I usually work in
two Dimensions but it's been done in
three and four dimensions four
dimensions being our space and then the
ultimate objective of this is it makes
calculations does it make them easier or
does it make impossible it makes them
possible yeah and if that wasn't enough
by the way you know doing a PhD in
quantum gravity Ryan also happens to
make games it's called flaggle it's a
flag with one g l e dot IO and another
one is called Wikileaks which I actually
quite enjoy it's like the Wikipedia game
but you don't get to see the article
what's your working relationship like
with your supervisor like how does that
no it's brilliant I have a very good
working relationship with my supervisor
I mean I'm also very lucky that the
things I'm interested in are also
interesting to my supervisor as well I
think we have very similar interests and
so that does help did you choose him as
a supervisor yeah I did I did choose
them as a supervisor and I'm very happy
I did because it's worked out very well
I remember the PHD I think it's been
pretty successful is this just random
stuff yeah no this is actually us
calculating too we just put what
literally whatever you want yeah
there'll be with someone who's just like
you know
there's a lot of meetings as you just
saw but there's also lots of reading of
reading of new papers reading of old
papers or reading of textbooks learning
of new areas of theoretical physics that
maybe I don't know as well it'd be good
to know the rest of time is goes between
calculating or programming I would say
it's the vast majority of the
researchers you're saying but even then
there's a backing forward to that
because to do the physics uh on pen and
paper before and relies on some very
high level maths before I even go
anywhere near a computer the physics
department here is huge and I think
that's a that's a massive benefit like
if I need to talk to an Xbox something
like for example say I want to talk
about cosmology then behind where you're
sat there's the the dwb and then Pedro
Ferreira I've had meetings with him
before talking just about cosmology or I
can then go off to the maths department
and talk some to algebraic geometers or
I can talk to the physicist in the math
department too and we talk about if I'm
stuck with something there is an expert
somewhere and that's one thing that's
quite nice about being in quite a big
department I mean as a graduate student
you're not necessarily so involved in
the colleges as you are as an
undergraduate but it is still quite nice
so having those kind of social
connections and stuff so I mean I'm
friends with people that I probably
would have never met if it wasn't
through colleges like one of my closest
friends at Oxford is in a seriology so
like ancient Iraq and I don't think I
would have ever met him if it wasn't for
uh for colleges it's great and it's very
collaborative too so the whole building
was designed such that you could either
work by yourself or collaborate or very
collaboratively I don't think
necessarily being at Oxford has made it
more intimidating as time's gone again
maybe when you first start but it
doesn't take long for that to disappear
because it's very relaxed not what I
would expect you to say actually it's
actually quite relaxing it's very
relaxing it's very relaxing yeah and
then people are very kind very friendly
and so it's a very yeah it's very nice
but I mean really but just a bunch of
nerds right that's all yeah we're a
bunch of nerds and we just hang out and
talk about physics that's what we do I
had one more thing to do before I left
Oxford well two things I gave a talk to
the physics society that I used to be on
the committee of about science
communication and YouTube and it was
great to meet so many of you there but I
also had a book to deliver to my College
library
partly to inspire feature physicists at
St Peters to take the path of
atmospheric study and partly to bring me
closure
what's after this what do you want to do
after the PHD oh that's not a question
Johnny it's an easy one this one I want
to continue an Academia if I can yeah I
mean there's a level of course it's a
competitive thing so one one step at
times yeah is to remain in Academia
you may be the first person in the
history of this series to actually give
that on
genuinely I think you might be
University is just one part of your time
on Earth whether you're an academic or a
sensible person with a real job or a
YouTuber but it's a time that casts a
long Shadow the skills and friends and
memories that you develop at University
can last a lifetime but those memories
can be negative ones in my case they've
cast a shadow for 10 years but with this
trip I feel like I finally stepped out
of their Shadow and see myself as a very
different person to who I was back then
and just as I'm excited to move into the
next stage of my life moving past and
accepting what happened to me I'm
excited to see where Thomas's career
goes and how his positive experience
here in Oxford will influence what
answers he will contribute to some of
the biggest questions in the universe in
this video we went pretty light on the
mats as that's not something everyone is
interested in if however you would like
to watch Thomas and I discussing the
maths of his research in more detail
then there is a whole video of that over
on nebula alongside other bonus videos
from this PhD Story series and other
exclusive videos from me and exclusive
extra videos from other creators because
nebula is a streaming service co-owned
by more than 150 creators who all make
informative entertaining thoughtful
videos and podcasts by watching our
videos on nebula you get access before
viewers on YouTube do so can watch bonus
content and do so with no adverts in or
before or around any of our videos but
most importantly by signing up for
nebula you directly support creators
like me as your subscription fee for
nebula is split between the creators
that you watch allowing us to make more
and more ambitious projects you can get
a subscription at curiositystream.com
Simon Clark because we're partnered with
curiositystream the biggest and best
source of documentaries on the internet
with thousands of titles to choose from
if you enjoyed this video then you
should definitely check out one of the
biggest names in string theory Brian
Greene talking about the history of
quantum mechanics in exploring Quantum
history all one of the thousands of
other documentaries available across
history culture science and the natural
world so head to curiositystream.com
Simon Clark and enjoy a 26 discount on
access to both Services that's just over
a dollar a month for access to the best
documentaries and exclusive access to
some of the best thoughtful videos on
the internet with thanks to
curiositystream and nebula for
sponsoring this video thank you so much
for watching this video as you can
probably tell it was a little more
personal than normal and yeah this was
an experience filming this one thanks
must also go to Thomas for being so
generous with his time I'll leave a link
in the description to his research page
if you'd like to check out his papers
and I'll also put up on the screen some
suggested viewing if you'd like to watch
something next including a link to the
playlist for this PhD stories series
it's also a thing on screen if you would
like to subscribe to this Channel and if
you would like to check out brilliant
which would really support this channel
that just leads me to say thank you so
much again for watching please do pop
the video a like if you enjoyed it and
I'll see you in the next one